CIERRA RAMIREZ: Will
you please join me
in welcoming the following tech
style influencers to the stage.
Cloe Feldman, YouTuber, a.k.a.
CloeCouture.
[CHEERING]
Darren Moulden,
influencer, a.k.a.
Darren Wears It Well.
[CHEERING]
Ale La Chula, YouTuber, a.k.a.
StyledByAle.
[CHEERING]
YouTuber Jon Phenom.
And Brittany DKé of YouTube
duo, BritxBrat2Fashion.
[APPLAUSE]
All right, we go!
JON YOUSHAEI: And hey, guys.
My name is Jon Youshaei.
I'm going to be your
moderator this evening.
Can you guys hear me
in the back all right?
Yeah?
All right.
So I work at YouTube.
I work on our influencer
and creator marketing,
which basically means I have to
watch a ton of videos every day
and get to know what's going
viral, who are our biggest
stars, from 1 million to
10 million subscribers,
and just have a lot
of fun with that.
I call it more of an
obsession than a profession,
and it's something that I
never imagined at your age
that I'd be doing.
And I just thought
I'd start off,
before we get to this amazing
panel that we have here,
just to give a little
bit more context,
because I think tonight
is all about dress code.
It's all about fashion
and tech, but it's also
all about paying it forward.
Right?
And I think if you ask
anybody on this panel,
we'll get into it.
If you ask myself, if you
ask anybody behind you,
tonight's all about
giving what we
got when we were in your shoes.
And nobody got to
this place alone.
And I want to ask you guys in
high school, how many of you
guys know what you want
to be when you grow up?
Really?
OK.
Awesome.
So I wanted to tell
you two things.
There's no such
thing as growing up.
No such thing.
In fact, one of my favorite
quotes is that "growing up
is the moment you realize
there's no such thing."
Tweet it, tweet it.
That's good.
And there's no
such thing as being
one thing when you grow up.
[APPLAUSE]
And lastly, the things that the
people that raise their hand, I
applaud you.
You guys know more than
I ever did in your shoes.
But I guarantee you, what you
want to be today will change,
and all I have to
say is embrace it.
Your career will change a ton.
You will change a ton.
You'll get a lot of advice
from mentors, some of which
you'll meet today,
others of which you'll
meet in the most unexpected ways
on this journey we call life.
And I just encourage
you to go with it.
There's no wrong
answers and there's
a place for everyone in this
world when it comes to finding
what's right for you.
[APPLAUSE]
Awesome.
So let's get into our panel.
Let's give it up one more
time for them for coming out.
[APPLAUSE]
We got two mics.
All right.
Cool.
So I thought I'd
start things off--
I'm always-- one
of the questions
I love asking people
is, what are you
most proud of in your past?
And, what are you most
excited about in your present?
So if you want to talk a
little bit about yourself.
But just mention, of
all the amazing things
you guys have done
on this panel,
what's something you're
most proud of in your past?
And what's something that you're
excited about, moving forward
in the future?
We'll start with you
if you want to take it.
Or if you want to work on it,
we could start over there.
CIERRA RAMIREZ: Let's start
on the end right here.
[LAUGHS]
DARREN MOULDEN: OK, so for
me, I'm just going to--
JON YOUSHAEI: You want to bring
the mic up so we can hear you.
DARREN MOULDEN: A
little backstory on me.
So I went to school
for six years.
I did six years of college
and graduated with a doctorate
of pharmacy degree.
I graduated, and I
realized that I hated it.
And I also wanted to tap
into my creative side
and kind of do what I
was passionate about.
And so going back to his
question, I'm proud of the fact
that I'm a pharmacist,
but I'm also
proud that I had the courage
enough to go after what
it is that I love to do.
Because like he said,
you never grew up.
And so at 17, when
you're told, OK, it's
time for you to pick
a major and figure out
what it is that you want to
do for the rest of your life,
you don't always know.
And you go into something,
and you complete it,
and then it's like,
OK, I'm stuck.
But you're never stuck.
So you always have
to know that you
have the power to do whatever
it is that you put your mind to.
So that's how I went into it.
[APPLAUSE]
JON YOUSHAEI: Do you want
to take the next one?
CLOE FELDMAN: Hi, I'm Cloe.
I think something I'm
proud of myself in my past
is that I always have
really considered education
a huge part of what I do.
Even though now I'm
doing YouTube full-time,
all throughout high school--
I've been doing YouTube
for seven years.
So all throughout high
school, like, I really
focused on learning, talked
about it in my videos,
talked about studying for the
ACTs and applying to colleges.
And it's always been
something I've really pushed.
So I think no
matter what you do,
bringing education into
it is very important.
And then just something
I'm focusing on right
now is building a
team and learning more
about the industry,
learning more
about what message I want
to spread to everyone.
JON YOUSHAEI: Beautiful.
CLOE FELDMAN: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
JON YOUSHAEI: Give it up.
ALE LA CHULA: Hi, I'm Ale.
I do YouTube as well.
I think one of the
things that I'm
most proud of is
that I never gave up.
The journey getting to where
I am at today was not easy.
But I love that it wasn't easy
because it made me who I am.
And, yeah, I mean it
took me about four years.
And it was actually longer
than that, but once I started--
committed myself-- it
took me about four years.
But it wasn't easy.
And a lot of the things
that you guys are
going to be passionate about
or that you guys love, you guys
will find out that
it's not easy.
So never, ever give
up on your dreams.
Always work hard,
believe in yourself.
And I always say that if
you put the time and effort,
you guys can make
anything happen.
And now I have YouTube,
and I have three channels.
I also have a couple
businesses that I've
started with my husband.
And that's my future now, so.
JON YOUSHAEI: Awesome.
That's amazing.
Give it up.
[APPLAUSE]
What about you, Jon?
JON PHENOM: Yep.
Can you guys hear me?
So here's what I want to say.
This is actually
pretty big for me.
This is probably a
big moment for me.
It's a milestone for me.
I have a crazy story in fashion.
I've been professionally in
fashion for the last 18 years.
I just I just had my birthday,
so believe it or not,
me and my twin brother
just turned 40.
JON YOUSHAEI: Wow.
JON PHENOM: Yeah.
JON YOUSHAEI: That's amazing.
JON PHENOM: Well--
you're clapping for it?
What cameras-- Alex, we
still look good, bro.
So real quick, what
I wanted to say
is I'm Filipino
and not Hispanic,
but in New York and Florida,
apparently I'm Puerto Rican.
So--
[LAUGHTER]
But what I want to
say is, I'm Filipino,
and your parents want you to
be an engineer or a nurse.
And so I met someone who
worked for Russell Simmons
when I was 18, and
he designed clothing.
And I never knew that
that could be a job
that I could design streetwear.
And so I was like, that's crazy.
This event is big for me because
I also teach in a high school.
So shout to Frontier
and La Serna High,
everybody in Whittier.
Shout-out to everybody there.
But I was telling my students--
you know, I always tell
my students is like,
at the point when I started
to search my career,
I went backwards, and I
said, what do I want to do?
So of course everyone wants
to be a baller, right?
So I wanted to make money,
and I wanted to travel,
and I wanted
something different.
So when I met a designer, I was
like, that's what I want to do.
I took my folks, I sat them
down, I was 18 years old,
and I was like, OK.
Don't freak out.
I'm going to drop
out of college.
And I said, don't
worry, I'm going
to become an apparel designer.
And they thought I was crazy.
My twin brother told me
later that they were like,
convince John to
go back to school.
So I did go to school.
I learned the classes, all
my graphic design programs
and everything.
And there's a reason
I'm on the panel today.
I was a director of the last
three companies I've been with.
I've managed multiple
multimillion-dollar clothing
lines.
And yeah, so it's been a
great story for me, man.
YouTube channel
helps people learn
how to launch clothing lines.
So that's what I'm proud of.
JON YOUSHAEI: Amazing.
Give it up.
[APPLAUSE]
BRITTANY DKE: Oh, you
are waiting for me.
JON YOUSHAEI: Yeah, yeah.
BRITTANY DKE: Oh my god, I can't
believe I'm on stage right now.
I've been getting panic
attacks, heart attacks.
I'm here.
OK, so my name is Brittany.
My channel is fashion-related.
I teach people how to
make their own garments.
The outfit that I'm
wearing right now I
have a tutorial for.
So it's a skirt and a wrap top.
And I'm just really proud
of how far my YouTube
channel have grown, especially
being a sewing channel.
That's like one of the
least-searched thing
on YouTube.
But what I did to really
stand out on YouTube,
I used to intern for
Michael Costello,
and so I really started
doing trending fashion.
So what I realized was
people wasn't putting out
gown tutorials.
So I would show people
how to make your own gown
or how to make a wedding dress.
So the stuff that people would
send me from all over the world
was like amazing.
So I do have a
clothing line now,
and I'm just really
excited to see
where it takes off from now.
JON YOUSHAEI: I love it.
Give it up.
[APPLAUSE]
So there's a few things in there
that I want to dive deep on.
First I want to say how
awesome is that they really
owned that question.
When somebody asks you
what you're proud of
and all of that, you
shouldn't shy away.
I love how you guys really talk
about all the hard work you've
put in and all the great things
that have come about that.
Jon, you mentioned
something really interesting
that I think-- you know,
when you're in high school,
your parents obviously have
a huge influence on you,
as they do throughout
the rest of your life.
And they always want
the best for you.
But I think it's so interesting
growing up in today's world
where many of the
professions that we'll take
aren't even in existence yet.
And I want to talk about
to each of you guys,
how did you have that initial
conversation with your parents
that you were going to do
what your heart desired
and what you're doing now?
And do you have any advice
for people in the audience who
may be thinking the same thing?
Like maybe your parents--
it doesn't have to be,
hey, I'm dropping out of school.
It has to be more
like, hey, I don't
want to be a doctor, a lawyer.
I want to do something else.
Do you have advice for
people in the audience that
may be wanting to do a
more untraditional path
as untraditional becomes more
of the norm in today's world?
Open to anyone.
Jump in.
ALE LA CHULA: I feel like
obviously our parents love us,
so if they see that you're truly
passionate about something,
maybe in the beginning
they'll be very shocked
and they'll maybe try
to talk you out of it.
But when they see passion
and dedication, I mean,
I'm sure they're
going to support you.
But always start everything with
honesty, and if what they want
is not what you want,
speak up, obviously.
It's going to be your life.
It's going to be
your time, and you
have to make sure that
whatever it is that you do,
you're truly passionate about
it because it's something
that you're going to have to
dedicate a lot of time into it.
So.
JON YOUSHAEI: Yeah,
beautifully said.
Anybody else?
Any other thoughts?
BRITTANY DKE: Well,
for me, luckily
my parents are
really supportive.
I just remember-- I
barely learned how
to sew three or four years ago.
But I remember when I
was three years old,
I made my mom a pair of
shoes out of newspaper,
and she wore those
around the house.
Yes.
But she didn't realize--
she knew I loved
fashion, but she
didn't realize how big
it would be for me now,
because I'm designing
for celebrities,
and I've been working
for Michael Costello.
I had to say that again.
JON YOUSHAEI: I was going to
say, name prompt, name prompt.
BRITTANY DKE: He
designed dresses
for Beyonce, Lady Gaga--
JON YOUSHAEI: Casual, casual.
BRITTANY DKE: --and
Britney Spears.
I could keep going on and on.
But when you're really
passionate about something,
I just feel like
you'll succeed in it.
And that's how I
felt with my fashion.
JON YOUSHAEI: That's beautiful.
And I think it also
goes to say, there's
7 billion people in the world.
Like, small is big.
There's people who share
the same interests as you.
So if you're passionate
about something,
then there's generally a
lot of people out there.
And one of the reasons I'm
so proud to work at YouTube
is that YouTube
gives that access.
So you have an idea, you
can just upload, connect,
and who knows where that
will take you later?
Any other thoughts about the
parent conversation or advice?
Yeah.
JON PHENOM: Just a
couple quick points.
I should say this.
I did drop out of college,
but I went back later
while I was working full time.
I went back to school
online so that I could
teach at a high school, OK?
I'm not just-- so I'm a huge--
my twin brother is actually
an assistant principal.
JON YOUSHAEI: Wow.
JON PHENOM: Yeah,
so I'm a huge fan--
JON YOUSHAEI: Full circle.
JON PHENOM: --of education.
But what I want to say for--
what I always say
to my students--
so this is like a big
classroom for me--
is, studies are
showing that you're
going to work in a couple
of different industries
by the time you guys go
to get your careers, OK?
So that tells me
a lot of things.
Your degree is going
to be about the ability
to go through tough finals
and to weather through it,
but you also need
to have flexibility
in terms of having a skill
set that you can then
put to something else, right?
And real quick, I
just want to say,
on that note of attacking
what you want to do,
you brought up a good point.
You're going to do it.
You're going to be in
the workplace more then
you're going to be with
your family, your wife,
your husband, your kids later.
So it's got to be something
you're passionate about.
And in terms of attacking
it, what I don't see
is sometimes the hunger.
So you've got to be
relentless about it.
Quick story.
When I lived in San Diego,
I found the 10 brands
that I wanted to work for.
And this was before
internet, OK?
There's the portion about
coding and everything.
So when I speak I'll say, we
used the term "computer nerd"
when I was in high
school and then
it gets-- just like this--
it gets nothing, right?
But before, it was I
can afford a computer.
I mean, it was expensive.
Now everybody got
it on their phone.
But you've got to be relentless
about really attacking it.
So I found 10 brands.
I researched.
I went to them and I said, hey,
I'm going to be a designer.
I'm not one right now, and
I will drive from San Diego
to get you coffee.
And then when they said,
no, I would come back,
and I'd have 10 questions.
How did you get this job?
What's the best
thing about this job?
What sucks about it?
What's a tough month?
What's a good month?
What's a high and low?
Those sort of things.
So a couple of pieces
of advice there,
but that's the
kind of mind state
that I have when I attack it.
And so for this
18-year career, I've
done a little bit of
styling on music videos.
I was doing, you know,
I was a fashion editor
for a little bit, but it's
all been around brands.
But I use the same skill set
onto the next kind of venture.
And you guys should
have that too when
you're attacking your career.
JON YOUSHAEI: That's amazing.
Wow.
[APPLAUSE]
Any other thoughts
on the parent--
yep?
CLOE FELDMAN: Yeah, I definitely
agree with what you're saying.
Like anything you guys want to
do, if you want it bad enough,
you can do it.
And I think that's how it was
with my YouTube and still is.
I literally live,
breathe YouTube.
I am posting videos every
day, sometimes twice a day,
and it's taken over my life.
But I love it so much.
And I was in school.
I went to UCLA.
My dad is really,
really big on education
and has always been like
it's his main thing.
But he saw how passionate I
was about what I was doing
and how successful
I was becoming.
And I think if you have
that drive for something,
and maybe it's not exactly
like what your parents think
you're going to do, I
think just going for what
your heart is saying, yeah.
JON YOUSHAEI: That's
beautifully said.
DARREN MOULDEN: I would say
to just do your research
and present them
with that research.
And just kind of
like the same reason
that you want to do it and the
vision that you have for it,
just present it to them.
And research it and
show them somebody
that's successful at it already,
and that would be a good way.
And then also just always
come up with a plan.
So maybe it is
that you do end up
having to go to
college for something
that may be more career-driven
and not your passion.
Well, then maybe your
plan is that you'll
use that career to
fuel your passion
or to fund your passion.
So it's evolved
like having a plan.
As long as you
have a plan and you
know exactly where you
want to go at the end,
I think that's most important.
JON YOUSHAEI: That's amazing.
I think a lot of you guys talked
about mentorship and looping
in older people.
And I think there's a quote
that's, it's great to learn
from your mistake, but it's even
better to learn from somebody
else's.
Right?
And that's what
mentorship gives you.
Can tweet that one out, too.
[LAUGHTER]
So I want to talk about, a lot
of people talk about hustle.
Like a lot of people say go
out there, go hard, like, eat,
sleep, and drink your work.
You guys have all done it.
I think the thing that would
make it really specific
and add a lot of color to
it is if you guys could tell
maybe a story of something
like, now some of you
have got millions
of subscribers,
you're reaching so
many people every day.
Let's rewind back.
Like, what's a story of a
moment where something clicked,
you did something, you put
in the work that other people
didn't?
I think the more
specific we get here,
it'll really add a
lot of color to what
you have to do to get here.
Because it's more than
just saying nice things,
it's actually doing them.
And you guys have all done it.
Go ahead, yeah.
ALE LA CHULA: So before
YouTube, I actually
went to FIDM, which
is a fashion school.
I've loved fashion since
I was in high school.
And when I discovered
YouTube, I actually
discovered it because
my husband was like,
oh, there's this video.
I didn't even know
what YouTube was.
But I went on YouTube,
and then somehow I
trickled across a beauty video.
It was a haul video.
And I instantly became
fascinated with the fact
that somebody can
actually share the things
that they were buying.
I always see things from
a business perspective.
Back then, the video
that I was watching,
I think it had
about 20,000 views.
And I said, oh my gosh,
if 20,000 people saw
this video of her
haul video, then
if 1% of these people actually--
if I had a website and 20,000
people can watch the stuff that
I sell on my website and 1%
would go on my
website, then that's
like, so many people that can
buy stuff from my website.
So I always saw it from
a business perspective.
So then my husband
bought me a computer
and I started filming
my videos at home.
And obviously I
thought it was going
to be like an instant
sensation, but nobody
was watching my videos.
And I was very frustrated.
I did it for about two years,
and I had 1,000 subscribers.
And I would stay up till, like,
3:00, 4:00 in the morning and I
would Google, how can I get
more views on my videos?
What hashtags should
I use on my videos?
Or what tags should
I put on my videos?
I would not sleep because
I wanted this so bad,
and I had to figure
out a way to do it.
And despite the fact that
nobody was watching my videos
and people would laugh at me
for still filming and uploading
and editing, I was still doing
it because it was something
that I truly, truly loved.
Fast forward about
three years after that.
My brother said, you know, they
make these videos in Spanish.
And the first thing I did
was I went into YouTube,
and I typed in
"what's in my bag?"
That was one of the big
popular videos back then.
It was about 100,000
videos came up.
And then I typed in
[SPEAKING SPANISH],, which
is the same exact
thing, but in Spanish.
And it was about 300 videos.
And I speak Spanish.
So then I thought to
myself, this market
has not been tapped into.
So I started uploading
videos in Spanish.
I didn't give up.
I didn't give up
on the fact that--
I'm uploading, I'm uploading--
I was trying to figure out
ways on how I can get in there.
My YouTube channel
now has over-- it
has 1.3 million subscribers.
JON YOUSHAEI: Wow.
ALE LA CHULA: If
you would have--
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
If you guys would
have told me that I
was going to have a channel
that big four or five
years ago, I would
have been like,
yeah, I'm dreaming
about it, but I
don't think I'm actually
going to ever get there
because no one is
watching my stuff.
So I don't even remember
what the question was,
but if you guys--
JON YOUSHAEI: A story of hustle.
I think you nailed it.
ALE LA CHULA: Yes.
So I did not sleep,
trying to figure out
how I can make this happen
because I truly wanted it.
And I guess moral of the story
is if you guys want something,
even if it doesn't seem like
it's going to happen for you,
I promise if you guys
keep working at it,
you eat, breathe, sleep your
passion, you guys will make it.
JON YOUSHAEI: Amazing.
[APPLAUSE]
Any other stories of hustle?
BRITTANY DKE: Well,
for me, before YouTube
I was working at Disneyland.
Yeah.
JON YOUSHAEI: Right.
[SQUEALS FROM AUDIENCE]
BRITTANY DKE: Yeah, the
happiest place on earth.
JON YOUSHAEI: Got some
Disney fans up here.
BRITTANY DKE: So they say.
But no.
I just remember when I
started working at Disneyland,
I started my YouTube
channel, but I would always
find myself sketching out
outfits at the register.
And I'm just like,
you know, there'll
be a time to clock out, and
I'd be, like, all right.
And then I'm
scrubbing the gutters
and I'm just like,
why am I doing this?
It's not fun.
So what I did was I
took my last paycheck,
and that's when I
started my business.
And so it kind of
launched from there.
And then I took a percentage
of that last paycheck,
and then I used
it for my YouTube
to invest in better
equipment, material.
And so from there,
everything seems
to have worked out for me.
But YouTube definitely
takes a lot of hard work.
A lot of hard work.
I find myself sewing at 5:00 in
the morning, but it's so fun.
Oh my god, like I'm
sewing, and it's just like,
it doesn't feel like work.
I mean, it's fun.
So basically what
I'm trying to say
is, if you have a
passion about something,
definitely go and do it,
because that's like the best
thing you could do.
JON YOUSHAEI: Absolutely.
And if I could build
on that, I think
that you touched on something
very important, which is--
what do you guys
procrastinate with?
Because that's probably what
you're passionate about.
Right?
Like you spend the free time--
we'll do some audience
Q&A after this, yep.
So there's a lot
of things that--
growing up, people tell
you to do a lot of things,
especially when you're
at your age, right?
But the thing that you
should probably be doing
is what you're most
passionate about.
If you find yourself
coding until the wee
hours of the night, you
should probably be a coder.
You know?
Don't fight your instincts.
Like, there is a
place for everyone.
And just like you did, if you
have a job and at some point
you will have to find a
way to make ends meet, find
in-between work, but
if you find yourself
doing that in your free
time and procrastinating,
then that's probably
what you should
be doing as a profession.
And there's a way.
We are lucky.
We are so lucky to live in this
day and age, where you could
turn that into something
that has an audience
and reach people all
around the world.
I think I also want to point
out from your story, the words
"overnight success," that's
a total oxymoron, right?
There's no such thing.
It takes years to be
an overnight success,
and that's how
people perceive you.
So I see it a lot in
part of my day job.
A lot of people start on
YouTube, they're very excited,
but they don't
have the dedication
that a lot of you guys all did.
It sounds like we'll
open it to the audience.
I want to give you guys a
final word before we open it up
to questions.
Is there anything
that you guys want
to talk about, like things that
you want people to know about?
I want to continue
the conversation
if you want to give your Twitter
handles or your Instagram
or your YouTube channels.
Anything that is a good way to
keep in touch would be awesome.
BRITTANY DKE: Well,
you guys can follow me
on Instagram, @britxbrat2.
[LAUGHS] britxbrat2
I think is on the--
JON YOUSHAEI: Oh,
and it's all on the--
BRITTANY DKE: Yeah,
it's all on there.
And also I host workshops
and classes at YouTube
once a month.
So you guys can check that
out on YouTube Space website.
JON PHENOM: Can I share a
little bit on the last part?
JON YOUSHAEI: Absolutely.
Go ahead, Jon.
JON PHENOM: Sorry.
I just have to say--
JON YOUSHAEI: No
need to apologize.
JON PHENOM: OK.
For me-- OK, so let
me tell you all this.
I have a fraction of the
number of subscribers
of these beautiful ladies
on the panel and, but--
JON YOUSHAEI: And this
beautiful gentleman.
JON PHENOM: Yes.
But look out for the collab.
They're all going to collab
with Jon Phenom at some point.
Hope, right?
But here's what I
want to say, is,
I was the guy where people
would say, oh, my friend designs
clothing.
And so I'd get a random
call from so-and-so,
and they'd be like, hey,
I'm so-and-so's friend
and I'm trying to
start a clothing line.
And I'm like, oh, OK, cool.
What do you need to know?
So when I started
my YouTube channel,
I just put up 20 videos
of what I would always
tell people to do in
terms of starting a brand.
And it was funny because
I was like, no one's ever
going to watch this.
I'd get like 100 views in
like a month or something.
So but I would say, go
to this YouTube channel.
And when I stepped away from
it for a while, it came back
and there was like
1,000 subscribers.
So I saw people wanted
the information.
And so now I'll do
a lot of consulting,
and they'll come from
my base of people
looking for the information.
So for me, that's where
something kind of clicked and I
realized I could
actually offer value.
But yeah, so I just
want to share that.
And for me, if you
just google-- oh, wow.
I just said, if
you google @Google.
That is crazy.
JON YOUSHAEI: Whoa, inception.
JON PHENOM: What camera?
What camera?
JON YOUSHAEI: Whoa.
JON PHENOM: That's crazy.
That's crazy.
You can--
JON YOUSHAEI: The black
hole is about to form.
JON PHENOM: --google Jon
Phenom, and you'll find me.
And then my YouTube
channel is /JonPhenom.
AUDIENCE: Woo!
[APPLAUSE]
JON PHENOM: Thanks, Jack.
JON YOUSHAEI: Any other
thoughts before we open it up,
or things you guys want to say?
DARREN MOULDEN: I think
I just want to leave you
guys with this last little bit.
With social media, we
are watching each other
and oftentimes will start
to compare ourselves
to people that we see,
and they may inspire us.
And we'll say, oh,
you know, like, I
want to do what they do.
I want to be like them, but I
would never be able to do that.
You have to always remember that
they had a story and they had--
they were in the same position
that you were at one point.
But they had to
make the decision
and have courage enough to go
after what they wanted to do
and believe in themselves.
So a lot of times
with social media,
you have to shut
it off in a sense
that you have to look at
yourself as an individual
and know that you are
fully capable of doing
what they had to do.
It's not going to be easy.
It wasn't easy for them.
They had probably
many sleepless nights
and probably wanted to give up.
But you always have to be
persistent and always know
that you can do whatever
it is that you want to do.
And also note,
social media people
are only putting there
what they want to show you.
They're not showing
you the back end of it.
They're not showing you the late
nights when you're up at 5:00
in the morning
sewing, or like when
you're editing your videos.
So you don't see that, but
you see that amazing picture
or that amazing video.
There's always work, hard
work that's behind that.
It's never easy,
but you can do it.
JON YOUSHAEI: Beautifully said.
[APPLAUSE]
Any other thoughts, guys?
Some serious wisdom
being dropped right now.
DARREN MOULDEN:
Oh, and follow me
on Instagram @darrenwearsitwell.
And darrenwearsitwell.com
my blog, so make sure
you check me out.
JON YOUSHAEI: Boom.
Nice.
Any other thoughts
before we open it up?
CLOE FELDMAN: I'll
plug my socials.
Yeah, so my Twitter, Instagram,
everything's @cloecouture.
And then I started a clothing
line last year called GLO
by Cloe Couture.
So that's all on
cloecouture.com,
if you guys want
to check that out.
JON YOUSHAEI: Cool.
Awesome, awesome.
I think we have a box to
pass around for questions.
CREW: Two questions.
JON YOUSHAEI: We
got two questions.
Maybe we will do it one from
this side, one from that side.
Yep.
Do you want to stand up, say
your name, introduce yourself?
AUDIENCE: Hi, I'm Kalilah.
I'm from GALA--
Girls Academic
Leadership Academy.
JON YOUSHAEI: All right.
Give it up for her for
asking the first question.
That's amazing.
[APPLAUSE]
That takes courage.
AUDIENCE: And I just
had a question, like,
what would you say your
main focus was when you
were going towards your goal?
JON YOUSHAEI: Great question.
BRITTANY DKE: I've got
to think about that one.
JON PHENOM: So for
me, obviously I
met this guy, Ali Ashar,
who was a designer.
So I would write it everywhere.
I would just tell everybody
or put out in the atmosphere
that I am a designer.
So I was on my way to
becoming a designer
and I was real serious about it.
I didn't breathe until I
became an apparel designer.
Then after that, it
was other things--
creative director and all
of that sort of thing.
[APPLAUSE]
ALE LA CHULA: My main focus--
well, when I started YouTube, my
main focus was always business.
I always knew that I wanted
to have my own business.
So I always made sure to keep
that in mind in whatever I did.
So I was always
figuring out a way
how I can leverage
what I had and actually
turn it into a business.
So always owning my own
company was my goal.
JON YOUSHAEI: Amazing.
[APPLAUSE]
CLOE FELDMAN: I think
for me, something
that's always been my focus
and always will be my focus
is getting better.
And that's like, at first it
was getting better with makeup,
and then getting better
with my video quality,
and now it's just getting
better as a person
and learning how to
convey that and spread
the message to you guys.
JON YOUSHAEI: Amazing.
[APPLAUSE]
DARREN MOULDEN: I
think a lot of times
when we start out with the goal,
we think of the end result.
And you have to use that
as fuel to get you there.
Because there's the
hard work in between,
but also remember the shining
moment that you see yourself in
or whatever it is that that
goal is at the end, how you see
yourself, remember that
and use that as ammo
to just really work
hard and go after it.
JON YOUSHAEI: Yeah, absolutely.
And there's actually
a lot of studies
that show if you visualized
yourself attaining a goal,
you're much more
likely to get it.
So if you begin with the end
in mind, you'll be ahead.
BRITTANY DKE: Yeah.
And for me, when
I started YouTube,
it was definitely also
to be a better designer.
I was actually going to
school for fashion design,
but I felt like I
wasn't learning enough.
So that's when I kind of
took a break from school
and just started teaching
myself techniques.
And then that's when
I brung it to YouTube.
And so, yeah, YouTube is
all about me teaching people
from all over the world.
And I know a lot of you
guys are in high school,
so I know prom season will
be coming up for you guys.
So if you want to learn how
to make-- yes, right there.
If you're gonna learn how to
make your own prom dress--
and guys, I have clothes
for you guys, too--
my channel, I'm just saying.
JON YOUSHAEI: I love it.
Any other thoughts before
we go to the next question?
CLOE FELDMAN: I agree a lot
on the visualizing thing.
I have always visualized
every single goal
through this entire process.
My first thing was
that I really wanted
to get to 100
subscribers and everyone
doubted me and laughed at me and
said I wasn't going to do it.
But I knew in the
back of my head,
like I just was picturing
myself with the 100 subscribers.
I already went out and bought--
I was going to do a giveaway.
I bought it before
I even got them.
So just really putting
yourself in that place
and acting like you already
have it is a big key to success.
JON YOUSHAEI: Amazing.
Great advice.
Thanks for your question.
We'll do one more.
CREW: Oh, right here.
Good morning.
Oh!
JON YOUSHAEI: Here we go.
[LAUGHTER]
Do you want to stand
up, introduce yourself?
Give it up for her
to ask a question.
[CHEERING]
Way to go.
What's your name?
What's your question?
AUDIENCE: My name is Honey
Tokyo [? Mashashige. ?]
I'm from Alliance
Bloomfield high school.
And my question is,
what really inspires
you to do this for you?
JON YOUSHAEI: Ooh,
great question.
DARREN MOULDEN: Sometimes
it's when you figure out
what you don't want to do
that will lead you to what
it is that you do want to do.
So for me, graduating
and becoming a pharmacist
and then at work I was bored.
I was like, this is boring.
You know, it's good
money but it's boring.
So sometimes it's what
you don't want to do.
When you're in that place where,
OK, I don't want to be here,
that's what drives you
or gives you the idea
or stirs you up
enough to say, OK,
what is it that I do want to do?
JON YOUSHAEI: That's amazing.
All high school students
should hear what you just said.
That's amazing.
That's so true.
What do you guys think
about that question?
What inspires you?
What's your why?
BRITTANY DKE: Well for me,
like I said before, I always
had a passion for fashion.
I definitely feel like
if you put anything out
on social media,
definitely do something
that you enjoy and don't
do it because it's trending
or is the next popular thing.
But I just really
enjoy doing what I do.
It's like just
waking up every day,
sewing, making
videos for YouTube
and seeing all the work that
people send to me from all
over the world is just--
I really enjoy it.
JON YOUSHAEI: Amazing.
BRITTANY DKE: Yeah.
JON PHENOM: What I want to
say for you guys individually,
when you guys are
thinking-- because everybody
is thinking about, how
does this apply to me?
So once you guys go
on your journey--
and it doesn't matter
what age you are.
Like I had a friend tell
me the other day, he's 35
and he's like, I hate my
job, I don't want to do this.
Help me, Jon.
So it's the same
thing that I would
tell like a 16-year-old kid.
You have to get
familiar with the things
that you love and don't love,
just like you were saying.
And then when you
get on your journey,
you might go into one
job and figure out,
wow, I don't like
this or I don't
like this situation, maybe if
you pivot it and change it.
There's another thing
that you'll love.
That's why I've tried so
many different things, like I
probably have 10
versions of my resume
but it all kind of
culminates with fashion.
And another thing that
I'll always tell people
is, when you do find
what you want to do,
find the best mentor
possible who's doing it, OK?
Like there's a reason
why someone is first
in their field and someone is
226th at the same industry,
the same job.
Right?
Like I would pay money to intern
with someone who's number one.
Or maybe they have a
huge ego and I don't like
that so I go with number six.
Do you see what I'm saying?
Because at the end of the
day, I don't want compromise.
You know, I don't want a "Devil
Wears Prada" situation with me.
Because that movie wouldn't
end like that for me.
Where's the camera?
For real.
It wouldn't end like that.
I'm Filipino for real.
So what I'm saying same for you
guys is find that best mentor,
learn everything you can from
them because their psychology
is different.
When they wake up and-- when
she's doing her YouTube video--
she has 3.2 million, y'all.
3.2 million subs.
Don't sleep on it.
So when she wakes
up in the morning,
her psychology is
different than someone who
has way less subs than that.
The designer, architect,
whatever it is you
guys-- realtor, whatever
you guys want to be,
there's someone who
has a psychology.
And success leaves clues.
So if you grab some
of those clues,
it will expedite your career by
decades and by money, y'all--
tons of money.
And that's not necessarily
the push for it.
OK?
It's about being happy
with your life, all right?
Because studies show
at about 80, 90 grand,
you can kind of get everything
you want in your life.
So you guys are young.
You'll be like, I
want to be rich!
I want to be a baller!
You know?
But in time you'll see.
But it's about finding
a mentor and then
getting the clues
of success from them
to really drive your career up.
JON YOUSHAEI: Great.
I think we're going
to start wrapping up,
unless you guys have any
quick thoughts to drop in.
Any quick thoughts
before we wrap up?
Cool.
I want to say thanks
so much for coming out.
The ending note, I want
to say, this is not
the end of the conversation.
It's very much the beginning.
Look us up on your program,
add us on social media,
come up to us after this event.
We want to talk to you.
We want to help you.
We want to pay it forward.
I want to give it up one more
time for our amazing panelists.
[APPLAUSE, CHEERING]